what do you say to parents who will go
through raising a child having a moment
where everybody has to have these
excruciation by fire learning curves
life experiences and then being here
connected honest wiser for it closer
stronger for it what is your advice as
we all ride the roller coaster as moms
we don't get a pamphlet yeah parents you
know just remember that everybody tries
to do the best they can
and i am
so proud of her
and
can you imagine not knowing and her
holding that in
all that time
it's been a roller coaster emotionally
for me
and this is not about me this is all
about paris but i have to tell you even
like a week ago i started crying like i
go through
because i look at her in a different way
i look at her now and i just see
yes this beautiful but
inside there's
pain
and it breaks my heart
i love you mom
but i'm glad that we spent all that time
together
and
it was hard for me
when the documentary came out
but i also wanted to talk to
a therapist
to kind of find out
what would be the way to approach paris
because she used to say i hate those
schools and da da da da
and i would shut her down
because i didn't know the extent of it
they're so mean i hate that i have
nightmares
and i'd say paris
you were naughty you didn't listen and i
had to get you out of new york can you i
don't want to hear it
and then to find this out
i
watching you two hug
there's just nothing greater
how we can grow forgive learn face
come together i mean i did kill for my
children
i love that okay
oh i feel like you're fool with my kids
uh-huh
let me tell you and that includes you
thank you kathy you needed me as a life
longer thank you
because again he's very very very very
paris is not like that
are you feeling comfortable dear
and
and yet she's out there fighting for
people like an el woods warrior and what
i love is that you can go through stuff
and come out closer and stronger and i
think that you guys are
just
saying that by being how you are and
does that give parents hope because oh
my god parents go through stuff anybody
can have hope seriously
well now
um are you thinking about having kids
are you ready to start your family i
mean i think everyone's just gonna be so
excited for that chapter
i cannot wait and i have to tell you
carter will be
the best father you should you should
see him
with nikki's children with his own
little nephew
he loves it he has such patience i found
the perfect perfect match in every
single way i mean
what do you think you're to be like as a
parent
so strict
i'm i'm so scared to have a teenager one
day and now i understand like when my
baby london which i'm going to name her
goes out one night like and sneaks out
i'm going to be you'll be having
something
so scared i don't even know you and
carter both will be and have like the
tracker on the phone like are you going
to call your mom and be like oh my god
it's full circle
yes
like
that's what they call karma yeah exactly
oh my god when the doctor called and
they were like it's a girl i was like oh
my god oh karma here we go and then when
the doctor called the second time and
said it's a girl i was like oh
i was put on this earth to learn all of
this to raise two good girls yes paris
you know you have found a voice
um that is all your own that is so
authentic
and
i admire it
i am so happy to be with you guys today
i've known you my whole life i will be
hearkening back to this full circle
moment of so much love and a life lived
and still knowing each other and
celebrating every second thank you
thank you
thank you
all right well please watch paris in
love which is now streaming on peacock
and you can also catch the show on e
premiering wednesday february 2nd
at 10 pm i love you guys we'll be right
back
[Music]